Uh,
as you know,
one of the longterm themes and our course
has been intellectual history and the
impact of epidemic diseases on
that this morning and not white.
I'm going to be looking at one of the
great medical debates in particular,
a great medical debate
of the 19th century,
which was to so called debate
between contagion, aneurysm,
and anti contagion aneurysm. Now, uh,
why would we be interested in it?
First of all,
if we're going to understand
19th century medicine,
we have to realize that
if you were to go back,
say to re reading the Lancet,
one of the major medical
journals of the 19th century,
or say the account of the proceedings
of the French Academy of Medicine,
you would see that they were,
one of the leading issue was
that was being hotly debated,
was the rights and wrongs the scientific
evidence for and against the idea of
contagion,
aneurysm and its opponents.
The idea of anti contagion ism.
So this was really a hot button
topic in 19th century medicine.
It consumed the middle
decades of the century.
So if we're going to, if part of
our course is to understand, uh,
what was happening in the
world of medicine, well,
this debate was really crucial in it.
Another part is not.
Another part of our interest in this
debate is that it brings to a conclusion,
um, much of our consideration
of Asiatic cholera.
We've talked about the impact of cholera
and we need to recognize that it's
impact was partly in the realm of ideas.
It's legacy didn't include just death,
fear,
social tension.
It didn't just leave behind it.
Sewer lines and water pipes and Britain,
the broad boulevards of
Paris and [inaudible],
the rebuilt lower city of Naples.
In addition,
it left behind it,
a major debate on the causes of disease
and epidemic diseases in particular.
And this is the debate between contagion,
aneurysm and anti contagion aneurysm.
It's useful for us to turn
to this debate awesome.
Because it helps us to prepare the
ground for one of the most important
discoveries in the history of science
and certainly medical science.
And that's the establishment
of the germ theory of disease,
which is our topic for next week. So, um,
what we'll want to do then is we'll
be moving towards the victory of
contagiousness them.
So this is a debate then that really
mattered in medical history now and
discussing this issue.
There are a couple of pitfalls
that I think we ought to avoid.
They're distorting and make it difficult
for us really to understand history in
general and history of
science in particular. Uh,
let me point out two pitfalls.
The first is a possibility of what's been
called the wig ish view of history now
and its application to science.
It sees history of science as a linear
upward march of truth moving steadily
forward over ignorance and obscurantism.
That is a history of constant progress
and it's reinforced if our history of
science deals and examines exclusively
the ideas that finally triumph so that we
study only a constant progress.
The march from one great idea to the next.
Another possible danger and pitfall
is what's called presenteeism,
which I might define as
the rather smug view.
That science all along has been striving
almost in Lamarche and manner to make
the benighted people of the past finally
emerge as smart as we are and we get to
look back condescendingly on
the thinkers of past centuries,
giving them marks for how right or
how wrong we now know that they were.
So to avoid those pitfalls,
but I'd like to do is to approach
this in a different spirit.
Next time I will take the more traditional
path of looking at the victorious
germ theory of disease.
And at that point we'll pay our respects
to the famous trio of 19th century
science that you all know of Louie,
pastor Robert,
call Joseph Lister.
And in doing that we'll notice that
what triumphed wasn't only disembodied
scientific truth. I'm not
disputing, let me stress this,
I'm not going to be disputing the
truth of the germ theory of disease.
But what I want to do is
something a little more subtle,
which is to notice that what triumphed
wasn't just disembodied truth,
but also a worldview.
And that when that worldview one out,
there were some losses as
well that went with it.
The germ theory of disease.
It's one of the greatest advances
in the history of science.
What we need to argue that although true
it perhaps wasn't the entire team of
truth and then its establishment as a
reigning orthodoxy by the end of the 19th
century because it does in fact come
to be held by the entirety of the
international medical community
really after around the 1890s or so.
And that brought with it
one of its consequences and
unintended one was certain
negative impacts on understanding of
disease that we'll be talking about and to
understand and appreciate this fact.
I'm going to concentrate this
morning not on the victors.
You'll know about them already to some
extent and we'll be turning to them for
the whole of next week.
But I'd like to look instead at someone
you probably don't know or maybe not
know at all. In fact,
just out of curiosity, um,
had before we talked about him
in our course and reading, uh,
how many of you had actually
heard of mocks fun patent coffer?
See, that's what I suspected. Um,
actually no one had heard of mocks von
patent coffer. So all the more reason,
uh,
we're going to,
the good news for you is we're going
to be dealing with him for the next 40
minutes or so.
Um,
he's the most sophisticated and
scientifically robust of those who were,
as we might call wrong.
He lived from 1818 to 1901 and one is
of the great figures of 19th century
medical science,
although his scientific defeat was
total and humiliating by the 1890s.
And indeed that might form part of the
background to the fact that he was to
commit suicide at the turn of the
20th century when he shot himself.
But I'm going to try to understand
that he was not just simply wrong,
but I'll argue that he
was splendidly wrong.
That is mistaken ideas actually saved
millions of lives and that third defeat
how to paradoxical consequence,
not only of advancing medical science,
but in some ways impoverishing it in
ways that are important and that we might
want to consider.
Well,
who was a mock pet Petten coffer
and since you hadn't met him before,
let me introduce you to him.
Uh, and here we use, uh,
in splendor and he was a German
scientist and physician in particular,
uh,
ah,
map of Germany,
Patten coffers associated with
Bavaria here in the south of Germany.
Let's look at that a little more closely.
And he was an associated,
especially with the city of Munich,
and I'm pointing this out
to you, not simply so that
you'll know where he's from,
although that's nice to know,
but this is extremely significant in
his theories and that he tends to be the
defender of localism and the autonomy
of Bavaria and Munich against the
centralizing tendencies of,
um,
of Germany as a whole.
So it has a political significance that
we'll be turning to know what were his
social origins?
Who was he?
He came from a Catholic
family of very modest means,
but lots of children.
And the family that is his nuclear family
didn't really have the means to afford
him with a higher education.
And he gained that because of an uncle.
He had a wealthier uncle who
was a prominent apothecary,
but alas had no sons and he wanted his
nephew mocks to carry on the family
business.
So Mark's Van Patten coffers started
out life by studying pharmacy and
chemistry.
And this in fact was to have an
impact on his medical theories.
But he soon discovered that he hated
the subjects he had originally enrolled
into study and eat,
terminally disappointed his uncle when
he enrolled in as a medical student.
And he gained his medical degree in
1843 from the University of Munich.
Thereafter,
he had a varied career for a few years,
casting about for what he
wanted to do in life. Uh,
he worked for a while for a mint and even
had a field attempt to become a stage
actor.
But in 1847 he gained appointment to
the medical faculty at Munich and became
also a professor of organic chemistry.
From then on,
he enjoyed immediate your career as
one of the rising stars of science in
Bavaria in Germany and Europe in general.
It became advisor to the
Bavarian government and a
full professor of medicine in
now 1854 changed his life and it did so
in relationship to an outbreak
of Asiatic cholera in Germany.
And it's interesting that this is the
very same epidemic that snow studied in
London,
but we're as snow was a contagion.
Honest patent coffer reached
the exact opposite conclusion.
Indeed.
Thereafter,
he became a lifelong
opponent of snow's ideas.
And what do you referred to with
scorn as the English water mania,
the English, he said,
we're obsessed with water.
Well, what was the debate and
why was it so passionately held?
Now the debate was obviously about the
issue of whether diseases are contagious
or not,
but it didn't involve all disease.
No one doubted in the 19th century
that syphilis, for example,
was contagious.
The debate was about a subset
of diseases fall in particular,
leprosy,
typhus,
and then what we might
call the big three plague,
yellow fever and cholera.
In other words,
the debates centered on the diseases
that were the most feared diseases of the
19th century.
And so the debate was passionate
because it concerned diseases that were
extremely important and it wasn't just
a matter of academic disagreement.
The decision on whether you defined
a disease as contagious or not had a
practical importance.
It meant what are going to be the public
health strategies that you'd devise to
combat it.
And the European powers were greatly
divided as to whether they should defend
themselves by quarantine,
the great Auntie
contagiousness measure or not.
Well, the two sides in the debate, then
we're contagion ism NMT contagion at them.
Let's start with contagent.
Awesome.
This wasn't a new idea at
all in the 19th century,
but it was unknown to the Greeks,
but it was part of Biblical tradition
and you've heard of it's popularization
already by the Italian physician for Daca
Storto and the 16th century contagion
ism had a widespread importance
in popular culture as well.
The contagion is an idea by
the 19th century was that
there were some infectious
material,
some people thought it was a poison,
a chemical and other words,
others that it might be.
It was pure speculation, a
living entity and animal. Cool.
You'll see that word in
John Snow for example,
in one of his speculative moments
that was transmitted in some manner,
perhaps person to person,
perhaps through the pores,
perhaps by contact with the sick person,
perhaps spine objects that had
been in contact with that person.
And you've just been reading
a very powerful expression
of the contagion honest
position.
And that's the work of Jon snow.
Okay.
But a potent thing to remember was
not down to the 1890s contagion ism.
And this may surprise you,
which primarily the standpoint of popular
culture rather than of the medical
elite.
Whereas anti contagion ism dominated
the international medical profession.
Most of men of science regarded
contagiousness and as a view held by the
ignorant on the superstitious.
And indeed the irony is that contagion
ism reached a nadir in respectability
just before the work of call and pastor
demonstrated its ultimate vitality take
to understand that.
Take an example that by now you know
extremely well and that is pledge
to the layman.
The spread of plague seemed to justify
the idea that by some means that people
still didn't understand it's
spread from one person to another,
but to little learned physician,
the case for contagion still seemed weak.
There wasn't a mechanism
to explain what it was,
how it was transmitted.
In many cases,
close inspection seem to demonstrate that
the disease spread without the direct
contact,
that the contagion is view
seem to postulate people
caught the plague who hadn't
been an immediate contact
with another plague victim.
Conversely,
where there was such contact,
often the plague didn't spread and people
who cared for plague victim sometimes
didn't fall ill.
How could that be explained?
Furthermore,
epidemics of plague began and ended in
the most mysterious manner that no one
could plausibly explain
under strength.
In their case,
the contagiousness would need to discard
their theory of inanimate contagion,
replacing it with something
that was living. Furthermore,
there was the need for the idea of
transmission of her distance by water,
perhaps food supplies,
or later we'll see insect vectors.
But the debate was also fueled
by political contusions,
by politics,
because major conclusions followed
from the position that one adopted
contagiousness in their
scientific conclusions or
people who buttress the power
of the state.
Because in the name of state power,
one could institute the most draconian
measures cordons lots of reptoids
quarantine.
You could see quester sequester
and confined individuals.
You could limit civil liberty and you
could radically control the movement of
goods and of trade.
So one of the results then
of contagiousness them,
you can see here,
um,
the idea here you have cholera,
yellow fever and plug trying to
enter the citadel at the gates.
And here we have quarantine
and the draconian measures,
uh, that follow from that
cleanliness. Uh, you know the film,
by now you're experts on the filth
theory of disease and the measures to be
adopted against it. So the
idea of contagion, aneurysm,
buttressed. Those ideas have a strong,
powerful state interventionism.
Now let's turn then to their opponents,
the anti contagiousness,
the people who were skeptical with
regard to the ideas of Jon snow.
These were largely associated
with the political left.
Why auntie contagion
aneurysm implied free trade.
It was associated with liberalism and
with the defense of individual liberties
against arbitrary state bureaucracies.
It implied opposition to extreme and
sometimes violent plagued measures of
public health,
so it wasn't a by conclude incidents that
it was a good idea to look at a map of
Germany because the most important of the
contagiousness Robert Call was an icon
and promoter of the power of
the centralized German state.
He worked in Berlin and that wasn't by
chance and he defended the centralizing
and imperial interests
of the German Reich.
Worst Petin coffer was a liberal who
championed the local interests of Bavaria
and Munich and indeed his theories
coincided both medically and politically.
There was some times
referred to as localism.
Another way of seeing the stakes in
this debate is to remember that Britain
long opposed the contagiousness position.
There were big part in part
on for political and economic
reasons that is to say
Britain was ranged in the international
conferences largely with Auntie
contagiousness in part because it's
interest prospered best through free trade
and it felt threatened
by medical arguments that
implied that the state should
interfere with commerce impounding
British ships and quarantining their crews
for 40 days.
The Anti contagiousness also had the
imprimatur should we like of tradition of
the authority of tradition.
Their views were sanctioned by Hippocrates
and Galen and were buttressed by a
whole panoply of ideas
that had grown up later.
But we're a,
if we like a compatible with
the traditional practice
of medicine with the idea
of atmospheric influences of the
epidemic constitution as it was called,
a bit of jargon for you of the atmosphere
and it was compatible with the filth
and Maya theory.
Let's also remember that anti contagion
ism inspired some robust health measures
as well and it saved lives.
Anti contagion aneurysm was to view of
people like Chadwick commune known now
and his associates Southwood Smith.
It was the view of [inaudible] and the
second empire and it was the official
doctrine of Rasaka mental that
is the rebuilding of Naples
now in the history of medicine and
public health and epidemiology,
the color of epidemic of 1854 looms large
giving rise to two foundational texts
of Epidemiology on opposite
sides of the debate.
On the one side we see John
Snow and you've read is on
the mode of communication
of cholera,
the final version of which
it was first drafted in 1849.
But the, uh, the draft that you
have appeared after this event,
and this was the classic statement of the
contagiousness view to the extent that
it could be supported without the
definitive evidence later provided by
microscopy.
So snow did everything that it was
possible to do purely on the basis of
epidemiological evidence.
There was going to need to be a conceptual
shift in order to clinch his view and
demonstrate it so that
it was broadly accepted.
On the other side,
we see a book that's been a,
it's not even on our own reading list,
a book that's been largely forgotten.
This is Max von patent coffers work
called investigations and observations on
the method of spread of cholera published
in 1855 and this I should say that
pattern coffer was no less rigorous
as an epidemiologist than Jon snow.
And this was a major foundational
texts in epidemiology.
It was a study of the 1854 epidemic in
Bavaria reaching conclusions that were
diametrically opposed to those of snows.
So from 1854 cholera became a lifelong
preoccupation of mocks Fon Patton coffer.
And he devoted himself to the
epidemiological study of the disease,
staking his reputation on high
profile debates with Robert Kaul.
He was to write some 200 articles and
books during his lifetime on a whole range
of scientific topics,
but the largest number about 60 we're
devoted to cholera and its transmission
and costs.
So Petten coffer.
And the reason we're dealing with him
now is he was the last major and the best
defender of the antique contagiousness
doctrine of Miasma TISM.
In other words,
and he defended it until his death.
At The dawn of the 20th century,
he adopted the traditional
doctrine dating back to antiquity,
but provided with with the new
evidence based scientific underpinning.
Well,
why was patent coffer not convinced
by snow when it came to cholera?
Part of the reason,
you know,
contagion ism patent coffers said,
and in this he was right.
It didn't produce a really plausible
mechanism for the transmission of the
disease.
It correlated cholera
cases with drinking water,
but to Petten coffer,
there seem no means of explaining
exactly what was transmitted or how.
Also,
as you know,
petting coffer had been trained as a
chemist and he looked at the traditional
idea that the collar a poison with some
sort of chemical substance and he argued
that it was entirely improbable,
improbable that a dcs could be spread.
Then in the manor postulated looking
at London and the river Thames,
how could a poison contaminating the
Thames if it was a chemical not be
infinitely diluted?
Okay.
Furthermore,
he said there was a whole series of
what we might call cholera mysteries.
That snows position
didn't help to aluminate.
Why did an epidemic
start and why did it end?
Why could doctors provide their services
in the midst of an epidemic of cholera
and yet not fall?
Ill have it themselves?
What caused the pronounced
seasonality of Colorado?
Why was its onset almost invariably in
the spring and the summer and why did an
outbreak? We seem to ed with
the onset of cold weather.
And then lastly for the moment there was
what we might call the problem of Leon.
That is the great second city of France.
If cholera is contagious and if it
follows the great routes of trade and
Population Movement,
why is it that there are nonetheless
major centers that escaped throughout the
19th century?
Leo was the second largest city in
France located at the hub of a network of
trade and transportation
and it had all the earth.
It was a great textile
center of manufacturing.
Okay.
And with and had all the urban problems
of an industrial center at its time.
If ever patent coffer would say there
was a city that seemed primed to be
devastated by Asiatic cholera.
It was Leone,
and yet her to escape the visitations
of this exotic Asiatic outsider.
Well,
what was Patton coffers theory?
And it was his delight to believe that
he could provide an apparently clear
epidemiologically based explanation
for all of those cholera mysteries.
Indeed part,
another aspect of his theory that Robert
Kaul discovered the Vibrio cholerae.
You've seen a picture of the Vibrio and
he discovered it in 1883 petnin coffer
didn't reject the idea of the Vibrio.
Instead,
he incorporated it elegantly into his
larger theory explaining that it played a
role in the etiology of cholera,
but that its role and its mechanism were
completely different from the ones that
cock espoused
patents.
Coffers theory is often referred to
as the groundwater theory we've seen.
It can be called localism.
It can be called the groundwater theory.
Okay.
The simplest approach to his method is
a very simple mathematical equation that
he was very fond of himself
for illustrative purposes.
It was perhaps the simple of
all mathematical formulas.
X Plus y equals z.
Uh,
what did that mean? Tamoxifen
patent coffer? Well, for him,
Z was a cholera outbreak.
The result then of combining x and y,
it's produced,
in other words,
under certain specific
conditions of two other factors,
the x factor and the why factor,
the x factor,
he said was the presence of
the Vibrio cholerae. You see,
he accepts that the Vibrio plays a role,
but for Patton coffer,
the Vibrio itself on its own
would never make you sick.
You could swallow it quite safely
and remain entirely healthy.
He regarded it as harmless on its own.
And as we'll see in a moment,
he carried out a famous auto experiment
in which he tried to demonstrate
conclusively the truth of his view.
In other words,
he made himself a cocktail of
the Vibrio cholerae and drank it,
and in fact,
he remained healthy and therefore I'm
persuaded to the end of his life that the
Vibrio on its own was harmless.
Okay.
He was to say that the Vibrio causes
disease and an entirely different but
orthodox,
Maya's Madec manner.
The danger around doesn't arise when
the [inaudible] contaminates food and
drinking water.
The problem is different.
It happens when the Vibrio gets into
the soil beneath a major city and their
Petten coffer,
a horticultural analogy referring
to germination or fermentation.
After the Vibrio gained access to
the soil under certain conditions,
it could germinate like a plant and
give off its poison into the air.
Above that the population inhaled and
those who were susceptible fell ill in
large numbers and it was then that an
onset that you'd have the onset of an
epidemic.
So in 19th century medical parlance,
cholera was an example of a whole category
of diseases that were called Xy modic
diseases,
diseases caused by fermentation.
So that we've see the x factor
involves the Vibrio cholerae side.
Then that why factor was
simply those local conditions,
again,
localism that were necessary
for fermentation to take
place and for poison to be
given off into the atmosphere.
So what makes up the why factor?
So again,
let's think of horticulture
and the growth of a plant.
A plant doesn't need only soil to develop.
It also needs nutrients and fertilizer.
And here was the critical
role of filth and excrement.
They were in patent coffers,
mind the nutrients for this plant,
the Vibrio cholerae.
So unsanitary urban conditions literally
fed the Vibrio sewage was dangerous,
not because it got into the water,
but because it's seeped into
the soil beneath the city,
nourishing the Vibrio and
giving rise to fermentation,
but there's more to it.
And patent coffers epidemiology like a
plant fermentation required a number of
other preconditions. It needed
water. Plants always need water.
It needed a warm temperature.
It needed air and porous
soil in which to grow.
And it was at this point that we see
why patents coffers theory is sometimes
called the groundwater theory.
Groundwater was important to his analysis
because he considered variations in
the water table beneath the city to be
a measure of the capacity of its soil
beneath the city to support fermentation
and give rise to cholera epidemics to
higher water table would be like flooding
and that would kill the plant too low
a table would be like
a drought or a desert.
So for cholera epidemic,
the was an ebbing water
table that left moist,
porous soil above it,
a condition that was likely to be
characteristic of the early summer,
and indeed Petten coffer now thought he
understood the seasonality of cholera,
he could explain it seasonality
by reference to the water
table of European and
other cities.
So armed with this theory,
Petten coffer proceeded to conduct
exhaustive epidemiological studies of the
local conditions of localities
vulnerable to cholera
for Petten coffer.
It seemed obvious why mountainous areas.
The Alps,
for example, didn't, weren't
afflicted with cholera. There.
There was such a deep layer of insulation
between the groundwater and the
population who are therefore
protected from the collar poison.
Similarly,
desert areas provided no
conditions for fermentation.
Pim Petten coffer also thought
that he had solved the Leo problem
by investigating and studying Leon,
he realized that it was built on a thick
layer of impenetrable granted was built
on stone and therefore
provided no opportunity for
fermentation and germination.
The best conditions were provided by
cities that were built at sea level on a
loo,
veal porous soil.
This could explain why
Naples was ravaged Paris,
London,
Calcutta,
and then he decided being
an honest scientist that he
should also investigate in
particular the hard case,
the one that seemed to conflict with
his theories and that was the island of
Malta.
Malta was built on rock but it experienced
disaster during recurring cholera
pandemics and he thought to
his own satisfaction that
he could solve the riddle.
Malta, unlikely all was not
built on impermeable. Granted,
it had everything to do with the
specifics of the stone itself.
Malta was built on porous,
soft limestone and not provided infinite
air filled cavities that if watered and
fertilized and warm conditions would
provide wonderful places for germination.
You can see patent coffer visiting Malta,
which he did and having his Eureka moment.
He did core samples.
I'm trying to say.
The patent coffer was a very conscientious
research and a strong epidemiologist
and he went further.
He argued also that he could explain not
only which cities where most afflicted
by cholera, but also the very
neighborhoods within them,
low lying areas close to the water
table would be vulnerable to cholera
neighborhoods built on hills would be
protected. Naples was a good example.
The lower city was ravaged,
the opera city was not and Petten coffer
thought in you why Neapolitans as you
know,
in fact agreed with him and patent
coffers theories were much admired there.
It seemed to explain Neapolitan history
and it was his theories that were the
very basis for the rebuilding project.
So he saw his great achievement of that,
of developing a single unified theory
with no internal contradictions that could
explain all of the known facts of cholera
and clarify those puzzling cholera
mysteries.
Now an interesting point about patent
coffers theories there now rejected by
modern science,
but during the 19th century they provided
a major impetus to undertake needed
sanitary reform.
His ideas therefore can be credited
probably with saving hundreds of thousands
of lives from a variety
of diarrheal illnesses.
Cholera of course,
but also typhoid gastroenteritis.
So this is a case of an idea that we
now know not to be robust scientifically
that nevertheless produced very practical
results that had a major impact on
combating epidemic diseases.
Patten coffer was responsible in fat for
bringing the sanitary idea to Bavaria.
He wanted to install sewer systems
to take away waste and fecal matter,
but not for the reason
that snow would have.
He wasn't worried that Bavarians would
drink infected water or eat contaminated
food.
He was afraid that the fecal matter would
get beneath the city and would nourish
the Vibrio and thereby give rise to
poisonous fumes that would poison the
people.
Soon as idea was to make the soil
of Germany cities in fertile,
so buy a new could do that by depriving
the soil of organic matter and
excrement.
So he wanted to supply Germany with
clean water but not specifically clean
drinking water,
but he wanted to prevent sewage from
gaining access to the groundwater and the
soil beneath the city.
He also championed the idea of sand
filtration of water to ensure clean water.
He thought that snow had
been seriously misled.
There was a matter of proportion here.
Snow he said was really concentrated on
the few leaders that a person consumed
that water.
He argued no matter how contaminated
would actually do no harm.
The real issue was the massive
quantity of water of domestic,
industrial or household waste that
carried fertilizer to the city soil and
they're bred disease now.
Petten coffer recognize then the clean
water and effective sewage and waste
disposal.
We're a central public health measures
so we had as his legacy Petten coffer was
the founder of the sanitary
movement in Germany.
He was also professor of hygiene
at the University of Munich.
He founded a journal called the archive
for hygiene in 1893 and indeed it's
still published as the international
journal of Hygiene and environmental
health.
He was the founder of the Mocks Fun
Petten Coffer Institute in Munich or world
famous research institute dedicated
to the promotion of public health.
He became its director and trained people.
It became a center of research
and training unique at its time.
It was an important figure and the
founding of the Johns Hopkins School of
Public Health and along
with his opponent John Snow,
he was a founding father in the field
of epidemiology is arguments though now
largely discredited.
We're supported by prodigious field work.
You could imagine him going around Europe
taking core samples of soil and rock
and correlating that with measuring
measurements of the rise and fall of
groundwater levels and correlating
all of that information with rainfall,
temperature measurements and the
history of cholera outbreaks.
And Preston coffer was tireless in
propagating as ideas as a lecturer,
as writer.
He was an advisor to the Bavarian
government and he became president of the
Bavarian Academy of Science.
Another factor was not patent coffer was
quite interested in something else as
well.
What made people susceptible and he
believed that poor nutrition was important
factor in that.
So as public health policies also
involved attention to diet and nutrition.
Of course some of his
recommendations were misguided,
but one measure he gave great attention
to was also the siting of infectious
disease hospitals in cemeteries.
A collar or a hospital or a cemetery
should be located on a hilltop,
far from the city center and down wind
of it that would prevent the cholera,
a germ from percolating down easily
into the soil beneath the city and would
ensure that any poisonous
miasma that arose,
we'd be dispersed from the population.
So we can see that he helped the way
condition the way Naples for example was
rebuilt and where the infectious diseases
hospital in not city was located,
which was high above the
city and downwind from him.
And as I said to prove his theory he
tried is dangerous auto experiment.
Uh,
his theory was losing ground by 1892 when
there was a major epidemic of cholera
at Hom Borg and Germany and patent coffer
and Robert call were greatly at odds
to prove his case.
Patent coffer challenged caulk to provide
him with a collar or a cocktail that
he volunteered to swallow Cox collaborator
golf key duly dispatched a file
filled with vibrios.
There's some interesting ethical issues
here as coffee scent patent coffer,
what he thought was a fatal
dose of cholera and fully
expected patent coffer to
die an agonizing death there.
Then various accounts of what happened
next one account has it that patent
coffers lab assistants intercepted
the package and diluted the dose.
It's also true that the collar or cocktail
was sent in February and it may well
be that the cold temperature in transit
attenuated the variance of the vibrios.
In any case, Petten coffer was
a man convinced if his theory,
he put his life on the line to prove it
and he'd Uli swallowed the file that Cox
lab had provided he felt seriously ill,
have diarrhea,
but didn't develop the symptoms
he recognized as Asiatic Colorado.
He rapidly recovered and was convinced
that he proved that the Vibrio cholera
does not directly cause the
disease not by being ingested.
Well,
there wasn't unhappy sequel for patent
coffer caulks microbiology by the 1890s
convinced the medical world of the germ
theory and miasmatic doctrine of all
kinds,
including patent coffers
own were discredited in 1894
he resigned his university
chair in 1899 he resigned from his other
offices and the 1890s also three of his
five children died and his
wife and in February 9th,
1901 patent coffer committed suicide.
Well,
there's a final aspect I'd like to raise
in my last minute and that is to say
the defeat of anti contagion isn't may
have had some negative legacies that it
took time to recognize.
One of the strengths of patent coffers
ideas was the stress they put on what we
would now call the environmental,
social and economic determinants
of disease for a time.
The germ theory of disease relegated those
aspects of medicine to the background
leading to a narrow gauge stress on
microbes and the attempt to find magic
bullets to destroy them.
So Patton coffer then
was ultimately wrong,
but I would argue that his
ideas were magnificently wrong.
They contained important elements of
truth and important and vital measures for
public health and for medicine.
Next time we'll take the high road and
move on to the victors in this debate,
uh,
pastor call LR and the successful
proof of the truth of contagion,
aneurysm,
and the germ theory of disease.
But I thought you needed a
moment with mocks Vaughn.